vor wenigen wochen wurde alles sei der
neue co parteivorsitzende der afd sie
selbst verurteilt russlands
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine doch was
macht sie mit unterstützung von kreml
propaganda in ihrer eigenen partei und
wie will sie eine afd führen die seit
diesem jahr als rechtsextremer
verdachtsfall unter beobachtung steht
darüber rede ich heute mit alice weil
hier in südtirol an ihrem urlaubsort
herzlich willkommen beim zdf
sommerinterview
[Musik]
alle frau valerie
hatte gegen glückwunsch sage ich schon
herzlich willkommen meine ich natürlich
beim zdf sommerinterview vielen
herzlichen dank für die einladung freue
mich sehr zu sehen wir treffen uns jetzt
hier in südtirol weil sie hier urlaub
machen richtig sie unterbrechen denn ab
jetzt für uns sie sind erst einmal hier
sie haben hier vorher schon urlaub
gemacht habe ich gehört und ich gleich
haben sie allerdings auch schon die
gelegenheit genutzt berufliches mit den
privaten zu verbinden sie haben kontakt
es irgend legt mit der partei die
freiheitlichen das kann man glaube ich
so was wie eine schwesterpartei der afg
ahlen die setzen sich hier in südtirol
dafür ein dass südtirol unabhängig wird
von italien ist das für sie aus afd sich
tatsächlich eine debatte dass sich da
ein stück italien aus dem land quasi
raus bricht also erstmal ist es ist es
schön wenn die kultur hier in südtirol
auch als solche gepflegt wird und die
freiheitlichen sind eine
konservativ liberale partei die auch eng
verwoben ist mit der fpö in österreich
und wir treffen uns immer wenn ich hier
bin wir treffen uns auch heute zum
freundschaftlichen austausch und dabei
jetzt seien auch bleiben das macht immer
sehr viel spaß weil die kollegen wer
sein netz an zur unabhängigkeit ist da
für sie kein thema höre ich jetzt gerade
heraus das ist ja auch eine private
reise jetzt die sie hier machen sie sind
als fraktionsvorsitzender auch
dienstlich unterwegs gewesen eine große
auslandsreise haben sie da bisher nur
eine gemacht und die hat sie nach moskau
geführt wenn man sich auf das programm
schaute da standen keine begegnungen mit
kreml-kritischen oppositionellen auf dem
programm und nach allem was man hört
haben sie sich auch damals nicht
eingesetzt für die freilassung des
inhaftierten oppositionellen noch weiß
nicht warum eigentlich nicht also
erstmal war der hintergrund der reise
ein völlig anderer er hatte überhaupt
keinen politischen hintergrund sondern
es war der unternehmerische
wirtschaftliche austausch wenn sie das
programm sich durchgelesen haben das
haben sie auch gerade gesagt dann werden
sie erkennen dass mich beispielsweise
auch mit der russischen zentralbank
getroffen habe mit deutschen unternehmen
also mit unternehmensführern die darüber
geschieht mit kremlnahe opposition rauch
einer deutschen unternehmen somit
deutschen unternehmen die mir sehr genau
geschildert haben wo eigentlich deren
herausforderungen im russischen markt
bestehen was auch ihre forderung an die
deutsche hre ehrung gewesen ist um auch
die geschäftstätigkeit auch für deutsche
unternehmen auch mit zu erleichtern die
russland sanktionen war natürlich ein
ganz großes thema extrem schädigend für
deutsche unternehmen aber da darauf
kommen wir später noch zu sprechen da
stand der deutsche aspekt bei ihnen dann
im vordergrund wenn ihnen danach vor
sich mit mit kreml-kritischen
oppositionellen zu treffen also bisher
ist überhaupt gar keine russland-reise
mehr geplant so aufgrund der politischen
situation was ich mir natürlich von der
regierung wünschen würde dass gerade die
deutsche bundesregierung den
gesprächskanal nach russland offen
halten würde denn dann hätten wir viele
der aktuellen probleme nicht sie haben
schon erwähnt über russland reden wir
natürlich gleich noch über das machen
wir dann gerne im sitzen in unserem set
wunderbar
[Musik]
frau wir haben russland gerade schon
angeschnitten das ist ja wirklich das
große thema der angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine die mehrheit der deutschen
verurteilt diesen krieg bei der ft ist
das nicht ganz so eindeutig da gibt es
viele stimmen die man aus ihrer partei
hört die damit sehr viel verständnis
kommen manchmal auch mit rechtfertigung
und es gibt auch mitglieder bei ihnen in
der partei die zum teil eins zu eins
kremmen propaganda verbreiten warum
machen sich da teile ihrer partei
eigentlich so zum verlängerten
propaganda am putins also erst mal ist
das in unserer partei und auch in der
fraktion völlig unstrittig dass es sich
hierbei um einen völlig
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
russlands auf die ukraine handelt so und
wenn wir über die sachlage heute
sprechen dann dürfen wir natürlich
niemals vergessen
in welche situation dieser konflikt
eingebettet ist
die die eingliederung der ukraine und
die planung die ukraine in die nato
einzubinden als auch in die eu gilt als
schon seit jahrzehnten als
als als etwas was die russen niemals
akzeptieren würden und das tat er nicht
nein das habe ich gar nicht gesagt nur
wissen sie wenn sie mit diplomaten an
einem tisch sitzen sitzt die geschichte
immer mit am tisch das hat übrigens
mitteln albright mal gesagt sie müssen
immer die geschichtliche einbettung
sehen und die russen haben immer ganz
klar und deutlich gemacht dass sie keine
gegnerische macht in ihrem hinterhof
akzeptieren würden und die ukraine gilt
als rote linie
seit jahrzehnten und so leichtfertig
damit umgegangen zu sein und die ukraine
nicht gleich auf einen neutralen status
gesetz zu haben das ist der fehler den
der westen sich ankreiden lassen da sind
sie nicht ganz auf der linie der die ich
eben gerade erwähnt habe also bei
anderen mitgliedern aus ihrer partei
heißt dass der angreifer ist nicht der
aggressor russland handel praktisch in
notwehr weil es nicht eben wert und es
gebe sehr viel rücksichtnahme auf
zivilisten das sind alles sätze die auch
in ihrer 1 partei sehr kritisch gesehen
werden da können wir einmal schauen da
gibt es stimmen die sagen von außen
betrachtet wird die russland fraktion
der afd als fünfte kolonne putins
wahrgenommen und man habe einen
kolonialen blick auf die ukraine in der
afc und ihr verteidigungspolitischer
sprecher im bundestag würdiger lucassen
der säuberungen eines afd
bundestagsmitglied im russischen
fernsehen ganz nah an der schwelle zum
landesverrat welche konsequenzen gibt es
denn bei ihnen unter ihrer führung für
diejenigen die sich so nah an die creme
linie begeben also erstmal sind mir
diese zitate nicht bekannt ich müsste
mit den kontext anschauen und die linie
die die fdp-fraktion im ukraine krieg es
ist ja kein konflikt es ist ein krieg
ein handfester völkerrechtswidriger
krieg ist völlig klar und wenn etwas
anderweitiges geäußert wird dann ist das
nicht fraktions oder parteilinie in
dieser frage aber dass diese äußerungen
ihrer partei schaden weil sie eben den
eindruck erwecken dass sie zu nah an
russland dran sind und auch putins
propaganda verbreiten das lassen sie
einfach so laufen nein das lassen wir
überhaupt eigentlich laufen um das klein
wie intern gibt es also keine
konsequenzen erklärung heißt man redet
über nein natürlich gibt es konsequenzen
aber das klären wir intern frau balci
sie sagen sie klären dass das heißt sie
wissen auch dass es eben diese
äußerungen gibt sie beschäftigen sich
damit die frage ist ja auch warum gibt
es da eigentlich so viel verständnis sie
haben gerade auch noch einmal dafür
geworben sich die gesamte situation
anzuschauen und möglicherweise liegt es
ja auch daran dass teile ihrer partei
schon länger eine ganz große faszination
haben für putin und das autoritäre
system was er da aufbaut mein kollege
david guetta hat fast dass man in 16
sekunden zusammen
putins russland autoritär antiliberal
und lange wichtiger verbündeter für afg
vertreter in einem weltanschaulichen
kampf unser gegner ist das was wir so
plötzlich globo hormonen der globalismus
in den farben des regenbogens
wer sich fragt was für ein deutschland
die ard will könnte hinschauen welche
länder schätzen
antiliberale gesellschaft portion awo in
brasilien oder donald trump mit dessen
anhängern teile der afg umsturz
fantasien teil und führen höcke will die
zitat schutthalden der moderne
beseitigen die liberale demokratie
aushöhlen wir deutschen denn leider
immer noch von ballistischen und
bestimmten hans und sprech truppen
reagiert
feindbild der liberale westen vorbild
vladimir putin ein echter kerl und
richtiger mann mit gesunden wertegerüst
ein lupenreiner autokrat als inspiration
für die alternative für deutschland
weil wir kommen gerade von der frage
warum gibt es eigentlich diese
faszination für putin auch nach dem
angriffskrieg und nach dem überfall auf
die ukraine und jetzt haben wir gerade
gehört es gibt durchaus leute die teilen
die repressive repressiven werte die
putin da vertritt nehme als beispiel das
thema homosexualität da ist russland
international sozusagen vorläufer für
eine repressive gesetzgebung wenn man
mal so hört was es aus ihrer partei für
äußerungen gibt dann hat man das gefühl
dass findet schon wieder halter ist bei
demonstrationen für die rechte von
schwulen lesben und anderen die rede von
zurschaustellung sexuelle obszönitäten
oder von dominanz des absonderlichen sie
haben gesagt sie klären so was intern
aber warum stellen sie sich nicht auch
offiziell stärker gegen solche äußerung
also sind wir jetzt ganz ganz viele
themen jetzt miteinander vermischt
worden also erstmal sie haben mir die
worte man ja es geht nämlich genau um
das wertegerüst und das werde ich
natürlich nicht so stehen lassen wie sie
mir das vor dem einspieler auch hier
gesagt haben dass es verständnis für
putin und für russland gibt es ist in
der international ist das ja jetzt
durchgehend sie warten jetzt ja auch
ganz lange dran frau bahn ag jetzt darf
ich auch mal antworten und vor allen
dingen auch da noch mal eingehen bevor
wir jetzt über die homosexualität und
die ansichten diverser leute sprechen so
das haben sie daher jetzt noch mal daran
gehängt mir ist es einfach wichtig
nochmal einzuordnen das wenn sie
internationale konflikte haben die
geostrategische so von hoher relevanz
sind und kreuzgefährlich sind der
ukraine ist enorm gefährlich vor allen
dingen wenn wir uns dort einmischen sie
sie sie sehen gerade eine verschiebung
der geopolitischen blöcke die sehr
gefährlich sind wenn europa sich dort
weiter einbindet wir sind der direkte
nachbar der ukraine die usa ist extrem
weit weg russland wird näher an die
volksrepublik china angetrieben und
dementsprechend haben sie jetzt eine
zweiteilung also eigentlich ein
wiedererstarken des denkens das
blockdenken des kalten krieges und das
kann ja gerade nicht unsere
sicherheitspolitische strategie sein mit
der wir natürlich in das
einundzwanzigste
jahrhundert aber jeden ball fing aber
dazwischen gehen denn wir sind beim
thema sicherheitspolitik sind aber sind
bei der frage was sich da im schlepptau
in ihrer partei tut nämlich da gibt es
menschen die im schlepptau dieser
diskussion sich nicht lösen von russland
die sagen diese werte die da vertreten
werden die sollen auch unsere seien
deswegen würde ich gerne mit ihnen über
das beispiel homosexualität reden sie
sind dem gerade ausgewichen was machen
sie denn mit solchen äußerungen mit
solchen menschenfeindlich winterraps
genau also ich bin dem gar nicht
ausgewiesen sondern ich habe
ausdrücklich gesagt ich muss das eine
was sie vorher einfach in den raum
gestellt haben einfach klarstellen wir
wenn es nicht klarstellen dann das ist
einfach durchlaufen das ist eine
stillschweigende anerkennung das ist
natürlich grund um mal so
homosexualität sagen dass gleich sie
spielen auf meinem privatleben an da
können sie mir auch die frage direkt
stellen ja was soll ich dazu sagen ich
meine innerhalb ist dass ihr mich dafür
wie sie als parteivorsitzende mit der
sache umgehen sie sind seit ein paar
wochen parteivorsitz haben sie müssen
ihre vorstellungen davon haben in welche
richtung sich ihre partei entwickelt wie
gehen sie mit solchen äußerungen als
parteivorsitzende rum aber wissen sie
diese äußerungen wie haben sie auch in
anderen parteien die haben sie überall
und wie gehe ich damit mal mit seiner
seite so seid so seit jahren wissen sie
ich kann damit umgehen das ist mir auch
verhältnismäßig egal es ist völlig klar
es ist völlig klar dass ich eine
deutlich liberalere sicht habe weil
sowohl das eine extrem als auch das
andere extrem sehr weit von der
lebensrealität von homosexuellen weg ist
und dementsprechend kann ich mich und
beschäftige ich mich damit nicht auch
noch als auch sowas einzusehen ist
selber jetzt gerade extrem die frage ist
ja auch die frage ist ja würden sie sich
gegen diese extreme überhaupt
durchsetzen hätten sie eine chance dazu
es gab gerade sehr interessanten vorfall
kinogruppe hat versucht sich an einer
stelle durchzusetzen gegen ihre
bundesvorstands kollegin christina baum
die hatte sich im zusammenhang mit
zuwanderung geäußert über den
schleichenden genozid am deutschen volk
da wurde der gruppe a bei den kollegen
von der ard angesprochen hat gesagt das
werden wir auf jeden fall klären das
wird konsequenzen haben nur einen tag
später hat frau baum nachgelegt und noch
eins drauf gesetzt und gesagt ich stehe
aber voll dazu welche konsequenzen haben
sie denn jetzt gezogen und das
besprechen wir intern frau banerjee das
gibt es beim öffentlich bekannt gegeben
ja recht welche möglichkeiten haben sie
also eine partei hat verschiedene
möglichkeiten die eine möglichkeit dreht
sich rund um partei ordnungsmaßnahmen so
und vor einer partei ordnungsmaßnahme
steht natürlich die aussprache wie es so
was eigentlich gemeint und also auch
noch nach zu setzen das natürlich
politische und klugen dann auch gegen
den parteisprecher das ist noch unklar
und jetzt nochmal politiker ist es etwas
was ich auch nicht akzeptieren jetzt
nochmal jetzt noch einmal auf ihre frage
zurück zu der fragestellung
homosexualität wie gehen sie damit um
es ist es ist völlig klar dass es diese
diese diese ansichten gibt nicht nur bei
uns und ich habe von zwei extremen
gesprochen sie haben eben diese fragen
frage gestellt was meine ich denn
eigentlich damit sie haben dass sie
haben das eine extrem dass sie wirklich
nur wenig akzeptanz und auch verständnis
für für homosexuelle paare haben dass
das so das ist das haben sie aber
überall damit muss man auch ein bisschen
lockerer umgehen ja das ist ich möchte
noch einmal darüber sprechen wie wie
stellt man sich als parteivorsitzender
auch nur hier haben sie mit der partei
hat christina sprechen dass sie ein
problemfall für die rolle auch genau
aber sie haben ja die frage gestellt
frau banerjee sie nennen das extreme
andere extrem aussagen auch andere ex
lassen sich gerade die frage noch
mitteldeutsche sehr gerne die sie nenne
es extreme und damit haben sich auch ein
problem sie haben die partei führen
die situation übernommen menschen wie
christina baumann ihre partei die sorgen
unter anderem dafür dass sie vom
verfassungsschutz jetzt als ganzes als
verdachtsfall für rechtsextremistische
bestrebungen beobachtet werden seit
diesem jahr wir haben beim
verfassungsschutz nachgefragt und der
verfassungsschutz präsident thomas
heilmann hat uns gegenüber jetzt mal
einen ersten zwischenstand bekannt
gegeben wir haben gefragt wie er die
entwicklung der afg als verdachtsfall
einschätzt und er sagt eine mäßigung der
afg sei bisher nicht zu beobachten
im gegenteil nach dem bundesparteitag
der afg in riesa und das ist ein zitat
sehen wir eine stärkung der
extremistischen strömungen in der partei
im neuen bundesvorstand findet sich kein
dezidierte kritiker des formal
aufgelösten rechtsextremistischen
verdachtsfalls flügel mehr das heißt aus
sicht des verfassungsschutzes freie
fahrt für diejenigen die eben ganz von
den verdacht dass rechtsextremismus
eingebrockt haben und die frage an sie
als parteivorsitzende ist wie wollen sie
das jetzt beheben
das sagt der verfassungsschutz das sagt
erhalten bank erhalten bank das muss man
auch einordnen ist ja cdu-mitglied und
verfahren wurde das ist toll das ist so
darum sage ich das erste
cdu-mitglied und berichtet an die
innenministerin frau nancy faeser von
der spd die auch vorher
eine unabhängige behörde ist aus ihr ist
ja auch nicht hier wird eine optimale
teurer so eine behörde
instrumentalisiert es gibt schon gering
sie stellen erstmals ziehen jetzt erst
einmal den geber im zweifel also dann
überhaupt rechtspopulistische
gruppierung oder partei wie gehen sie
mit um sie müssen doch wirklich sender
und empfänger das ist doch völlig
einfaches konzept so das fängt doch da
der sender den muss sich doch einfach
mal einordnen was ist der verfassen
sehen den ring als in hessen ist sie nur
wird sogar ein dienst den es sonst
nirgends gibt in cannes im industrieland
deutschland nutzt ihn hat dort
parteigänger um die opposition zu
verunglücken das muss man sich mal
vorstellen allein das ist logisch als
historische genauere erfassung schutz zu
einem frühwarnsystem ja sich der
verfassungsschutz wie es jetzt politisch
wird um eine oppositionsparteien noch
löcher zu verunglimpfen und einem weißen
unabhängiges gericht darauf muss man
auch hinweise hat schon gesagt der
verfassungsschutz hat ausreichende
tatsächliche anhaltspunkte für
verfassungsfeindliche bestrebungen das
hat das verwaltungsgericht köln
kiloweise anhin durchgearbeitet also es
gibt auch eine unabhängiges gericht dass
das sagte genauso wie die
verfassungsgerichte wo sie einen
ehemaligen cdu abgeordneten haben der
über die gesetze heute als richter
entscheiden soll über die ja vorher
entschieden hat also das gibt es auch in
keinem anderen westlichen land dass sie
diese vermischung der der
gewaltenteilung haben aber gut es geht
weiter aber es gibt ja auch noch
ausdrücklich auch noch explizit ihre
meinungen ihrer partei dann hat das auf
dem parteitag in riesa gesehen da gab es
wurde eine art schaulaufen der extremen
rechten hacke sagte dann nämlich zu
dieser frage was ist rechtsextrem oder
nicht wer rechts ist sinngemäß wer
rechtsextremist und wenn nicht das
entscheiden wir aus eigener kraft sie
klingen jetzt so ähnlich ist das so
ich klinge damit so ähnlich also es ist
dass das muss der wähler letztendlich
entscheiden der wähler und der einzelne
in der bundesrepublik deutschland ist
doch ist doch der souverän so und eine
unabhängige behörde wies der
verfassungsschutz sein möchte die ist
doch gar nicht gegeben weil sie eben die
parteigänger eben auch haben und das
zählt alles darauf ab ich merke das ja
selbst also man wird ja immer in die
gleiche ecke gestellt und es ist ja auch
irgendwann einmal auch extrem langweilig
ist noch eine ecke heraus
irgendwann muss man sich erst es
intellektuell enorm unter fordernd das
muss ich auch sagen weil immer die
gleichen knöpfe gedrückt werden und ich
würde mir in der tat mehr unabhängigkeit
wünschen aber auch von den medien mehr
unabhängigkeit wünschen auch mal die
regierung zu kritisieren
guck doch mal dahin wie sieht es in
unseren bürgerrechten aus wie wird unser
große sprünge mit der bundesregierung
führe ich natürlich ein anderes früh vor
unserem zeit davonläuft das floriade
bevor es die zeit davonläuft und einer
privaten verlage nur einer privaten
fragen zum schutz müsste sich eigentlich
mal mit den ganzen grundgesetz
verletzungen der regierung
auseinandersetzen das recht auf
körperliche
unabänderliche unversehrtheit dann der
freie meinungsäußerung der
demonstrationsfreiheit und und durch die
korona maßnahmen politik wurden diese
grund gesetze außer kraft gesetzt und
jetzt fängt man wieder ab dem ersten
oktober
diese diese diesem ausnahmezustand der
einfach unsere grundrechte außer kraft
setzung normalität zu machen ich finde
da sollte man mal genau hinschauen davos
ist jetzt leider den abschluss da muss
ich jetzt leider den abschluss machen
weil das war die zeit die uns heute zur
verfügung gestanden ist ich halte fest
homophobie ist nicht das thema über das
wir gerne sprechen würden
verfassungsschutz sehen sie auch sehr
sehr kritisch sie haben jetzt als
parteivorsitzender einiges vor sich in
der partei aber ich danke ihnen an
dieser stelle erst einmal vielleicht
gesprächen her dass ich damit robert i
das war das sommerinterview mit der afg
co parteivorsitzende und in der
kommenden woche geht es weiter mit theo
koll der trifft dann den
parteivorsitzenden der fdp einen
herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen und einen
schönen abend